so today we have a few cancellations to
dole out and it all begins with this
question
sent into slate's advice column now
anybody who sends a question to slate's
advice column deserves to be cancelled
on that basis alone
i cannot imagine ever facing a quandary
in my life where i think to myself man
you know slate might know what to do
here
i have never been in a situation where i
wondered
what slate might say about it and that's
mostly because i know what slate would
say they'd say that the cause of the
problem is racism sexism and transphobia
literally no matter what the problem
actually is the problem could be like a
flat tire or
arthritis or anything and that would be
slate's answer
but this guy who uses the pseudonym
suddenly the breadwinner
thought that slate would be the best
best place to go with his issue and
here's what he wrote
it's a little bit long but let's read
the whole thing bear with me he says i
am a new father to a beautiful 10 month
old girl
my wife's company has a generous
maternity leave policy and she has been
at home with her daughter since the
birth
and is scheduled to go back to work just
after her first birthday in january
she recently told me she doesn't want to
go back to her job and would like to be
a stay-at-home parent instead
i asked her why and she said she enjoys
being a mother too much to leave our
daughter to go back to work
when she doesn't need to it's such a
departure from our plans before the baby
was born she had a good job
that she enjoyed before going on leave
and had always been adamant that she
wanted to continue working even after
becoming a mom
we met when we worked at the same
company many years ago one of the things
i was most attracted to
to about her was her ambition and
tenacity it's really surprising to hear
that her career isn't that important to
her anymore honestly
i don't want her to quit her job she
earns about the same as i do and while
we could make ends meet on my income
alone
it would impact our daily ability or our
ability to save and we need to give up
one of our cars
and cut back on extras that make life
more enjoyable
i also just don't want to stay at home
mom wife
i really admired my wife for her work
ethic and i want her to set a good
example for our daughter too
seeing her give up like this is really
disappointing
i gently asked her if she thought her
change in attitude could be related to a
possible
mental health issue or postpartum
depression
but she didn't take that well she says
she only cares about her daughter and
that's where all her energy needs to go
right now and that if i love her i will
let her do this
i do love my wife and i'm not interested
in divorce but i'm seeing a whole side
of her that i just don't
like or admire what should i do okay
well i mean as long as he gently asked
he gently asked whether his wife wants
to stay home and raise their daughter
due to a mental illness
hey honey uh listen i i know you said
you love being a mother
you want to be home with our child
full-time i'm just wondering i'm just
wondering
are you having a psychotic break is that
what this is
i'm only asking what i'm just asking
i can't believe that didn't go over well
now
i admit that i might be judging this man
extra harshly because i am also the
breadwinner in my family and we have
four little mouths to feed instead of
one
and i personally really like supporting
my family i feel honored to do it
fulfilled by it
and i love that my kids have their mom
home with them
the idea of being disappointed about
being the breadwinner as a man
is completely foreign to me the idea of
respecting
my and admiring your wife less
because she loves being a mom too much
is also
utterly foreign to me but we'll respond
more to these ideas
in a second first let's loop in our dear
friend jill philopovic
she's a feminist writer who always has
exactly the sort of take you expect on
these kinds of issues
in a series of tweets she responded
empathizing with the man and empathizing
with men is usually not one of her
strong suits
and she said in part quote i realize
this is like the third rail of the mommy
wars but yeah lots of super ambitious
people
marry other super ambitious people
because they're attracted to ambition
i would have a really really hard time
being married to a spouse who chose not
to work
and now i'm really going to get myself
yelled at but i also think the issue of
example setting for a kid is totally
fair what example are you setting when
dad works for pay and mom does the care
work at home
lots of reasons not to want to see it to
set that kind of example for a child
at home work is incredibly isolating it
also occupies a pretty unique space
where it's centered on one of the most
fundamental familial relationships
parent slash child
no other job is like that which is where
the claim that staying at home
is a job doesn't quite tell the whole
story
okay now there's a lot to be said on
this topic we don't have time to say
most of it instead i just want to focus
on two things
maybe not even the two most important
things but these two things
first the idea that you have to choose
between being ambitious or raising your
children full time is asinine
ambition in the positive sense of the
word is simply
a strong desire to achieve some kind of
worthwhile goal
coupled with the determination to see it
through that's what we mean when we
speak positively about an ambitious
person raising children and tending to
your family in your home
requires a lot of ambition or to put it
another way
there's a big difference between
children who are raised ambitiously
and children who are not so to have
ambition as a parent is to be active to
be present
not complacent here's here's a very
simple example of
ambitious parenting and this again is by
far not the most profound example but
as i said a simple everyday example
an ambitious parent turns the tv off
says to the kids hey let's go outside
and play a game let's have a scavenger
hunt let's do some activity that i have
planned
some edifying and educational and fun
activity that i have planned that we're
going to go do
rather than just having you sit here and
watch tv all day
now this is not necessarily the parents
idea of a good time but it's good for
the kids in the long run and you're
putting the work and effort
in in pursuit of that long-term benefit
rather than simply letting them watch tv
and play video games all day
at the end of the day as a parent you
know
if you parented ambitiously or not
and you may be more worn out after the
day of ambitious parenting but there's
also a deep fulfillment that you feel
from it
and i would submit that in many cases
parenting provides
more chances to have that kind of
feeling
that sort of satisfied tired feeling of
knowing you put a hard day's work in and
you were ambitious and
you know you and proactive parenting
provides more opportunities to feel that
way
than a nine-to-five job does in many
nine-to-five jobs the structure is
already laid out your function is
limited
ambition doesn't even come into play
most of the time there isn't much room
to set your own path
as a parent there is no structure
but what you put in place there is no
plan
but what you devise then if you don't
put a structure in place if you have no
plan if you don't do anything
if you just let the days flow by
counting on the glowing screens to keep
your kids distracted
sure you're going to feel totally empty
alone bored and miserable
but that's where ambition comes into
play
second point no being a stay-at-home mom
is not a job it's not
a job is something you get specifically
paid to do
many jobs require you to punch in and
punch out you might even get a name tag
parenting involves none of that it's not
a job but it is
work okay that's the distinction here
a job is just a type of work being a
stay-at-home mom
is not a job but it is a type of work
running a self-sustaining farm is also
not a job
but it's definitely work the real
question is whether a job is a more
noble more worthwhile more
important kind of work than parenting
and the answer to that is obviously no
not all jobs are created equal some jobs
are more important than others
just as not all parents are created
equal some parents are better than
others
but speaking in broad strokes here
working for working for a wage at the
behest of a large company under the
supervision of bosses and managers
is not some kind of noble romantic thing
it's also not liberating
the idea that a woman is liberated from
the servile bonds of motherhood by
becoming a wage slave for a corporation
is frankly ridiculous nothing wrong with
working a job i do it
somebody in the family's got to do it
let's not delude ourselves about the
nature of what we're doing at our jobs
here's the other tough reality you are
replaceable
at your job totally replaceable we all
are
your value to your employer is entirely
based on how well you perform
if they can find someone who performs
better than you
you go from limited value to no value
and either way once you exit one way or
another whether you leave on your own or
are fired
the hole you leave behind will be filled
and you'll be quickly forgotten
that's what it means to work at a job it
means that your worth is quantified in
dollars and cents it means that whatever
you do
you're only doing it because and so long
as you're given money in return
and there's nothing fundamentally wrong
with any of this as i said someone's got
to do it
but it's hard to see this as somehow
more admirable than full-time parenting
jobs are mercenary jobs are temporal
jobs are revolving doors parenting is
none of that
or at least it shouldn't be which is why
even though i have a job i find
my real worth and value at home with my
family because that's what really
matters
and if you even if you don't have a
family um well you still
better find your worth and value
somewhere else you better find some
deeper more meaningful thing to find
your worth and value in
than your job
that's the case for everybody and so
parents who do this full-time
incredibly worthwhile and valuable thing
people who can't see that
like our friend jill and the guy who
wrote that letter are of course
cancelled well i hope you enjoyed that
clip from the matt wall show if you did
go ahead and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you can stay up to
date on all of our future content